الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام
على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم
وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين اما بعد يقول الحافظ النووي رحمه
الله في رياضه في باب احضار النيه
والاخلاص وعن ابي بكره نفيع بن الحارث
الثقفي رضي الله عنه ان النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم قال: "اذا التقى المسلمان
بسيفيهما فالقاتل والمقتول في النار". قلت
يا رسول الله هذا القاتل فما بال المقتول؟
قال انه كان حريصا على قتل صاحبه متفق
عليه.
ابي بكره رضي الله عنه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
another
kill are
messenger of Allah
we understand
the killer being in the fire
‏Why is the victim as well in the fire
with him?
And so he responded
because he was trying to kill his
opponent.
انه كان حريصا حريصا
على قتل صاحبه
الحرص حريص
الحرص الحرص
الحرص لانج هو الطلب الحثيث
الطلب الحثيث هذا يسمى حرصا الانسان حريص
على العلم يطلبه طلبا حثيثا
ويجتهد في طلبه
رجل حريص على قتل صاحبه
بذل جهده في قتل صاحبه
حريص
was
bestillent
الله سبحانه وتالى
‏That's it. Their wills the same. Their
intentions were the same. How do we know
their intention were the same? Because
they both came with deadly weapons to
fight one another. That's all we need to
know. Nothing beyond that is recognized
in
a cour in a judgement of this tye of
situation.
كلمه صاحبه
صاحبه
الصاحب
في لغه العرب
يطلق ويراد
به من كان
يشارك
الشخص او يشارك الانسان في شيء ما قد يكون
شريكا له في حياته قد يكون شريكا له في
سفره قد يكون شريكا له في عداوته
يعني يشترك معه في شيء لذلك قد يطلق كلمه
الصاحب على العدو مثل
هذه الروايه لو كان حريصا على قتل صاحبه
مين يقتل صاحبه لا كلمه صاحب في لغتنا
الدارجه معناها الصديق
لكن كلمه صاحب في لغه العرب في اصل لغه
العرب في لغه الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
يطلق ويراد به المشارك
المشارك لذلك عين ربنا سبحانه وتعالى في
القران قال والصاحب
بالجنب
صاحب الجنب يعني المشارك للانسان
عن جنبه
ولذلك اختلفت عبارات المفسرين في تفسير
هذه الكلمه قال بعضهم
الصاحب بالجنب هو الرفيق في السفر
وقيل الصاحب بالجنب هو الزوج او الزوجه
وهذا اقرب اقرب لانه اشمل لهذه الايه و
يعني
انسب لمعاني الايه فهنا يقول والصاحب
بالجنب
فعين الصاحب الذي هو يكون ملازما مشاركا
عن جنب الانسان عن جنب الانسان اذا الصاحب
لذلك جاء في حديث ابي هريره المعروف لما
كان اييه
حارسا يحرس
با بيت المال والصدقات
فجاء لص في الليل يريد ان يسرق
ف
زي ما بقولوا عننا زقطوا ابو هريره قال
لارفعنك الى رسول الله فقال قال اي رجل ذو
عيال وكذا وكذا
اشفك علي ف خلى سبيله
اخبر النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم في الصبح
ثاني ليله رجع
وحصلت القصه ثاني يوم في الصبح النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم قال ما فعل صاحبك
صاحبي يعرف عرفنا في نهايه الحديث انه هذا
مين؟ شيطان. كيف صاحبه؟ صاحبه نعم صاحبه
بمعنى مشارك له في هذه القصه
صاحب لا
يلزم من كلمه صاحب انه فيه ود او لا يلزم
من كلمه صاحب الصداقه لا يلزم
لذلك هو يقول انه كان حريصا على قتل صاحبه
فهذه النيه
مع بذل الجهد اوقعه موقع
القاتل
اوقعه موقع القاتل الذي ينوي الشيء
ويجتهد في طلبه ثم يحول دونه ودون مطلوبه
ومرامه قدر الله فله ما نوى
لك ما اخذت يا يزيد ولك لك ما نويت
يا معنى ف
هذه لذلك وضع هذه الروايه الحافظ النووي
في هذا الباب لان هذه الروايه وامثال هذه
الروايه هي من
اهم الادله في ابواب النيه
[Silence]
‏toan
circstantialidirstantialid
notally be 100% valid outside of an
ecosystem of circumstances
and
عمر رضي الله عنه
famous statement that the intentions are
for
and weased
what they man behavi if they deal with
us good we will deal with them in kind
if they us poely we will with them
accordingly ‏and their intentions are to
Allah. However, does this mean that a
person can claim their intention
is radically
radically divorced from their actions
completely. No matter how insane it
sounds. Of course not. ‏This is
ridiculous, right? A person burns your
house down and then says, "My intention
was, you know, I just we hear in,
you know, in this insane
world of the disbeliever that we live in
right now. Right now, we see the world
through the popular
opinion, through the popular lens." What
is the popular lens? We are seeing the
world through the perspective of the
disbeliever. ‏right now in popular media
whatever it is so you have a woman will
go and cheat on her husband say I just
wanted your attention it's because I
love you so much I love you so much that
I want to did this what kind of mental
gymnastics
does a cowardly
kind of man have to do in order to
accept this is a valid excuse
doesn't make any sense.
‏What does that mean? I to get your att
and so I s around but it wasn't I to
because I to get your intention I love
you so much I just don't know how to get
your attention this is one of the most
ridiculous absurd insane excuses it's
not an excuse
right and so what is the point here that
we making the point is is that we use
outward behaviors
‏and
beh and
person in
that is what was
what is the besting fact for a person
future if i want to i don't know anybody
could be good a bad guy could be good
and a good guy could be bad i don't know
what a
‏doutory
[Silence]
that is going to
articulate pattern pattern of behavi
right background check that's why these
things
‏We look into people
thisory we see one
right if I see a pattern of divorce with
someone I understand that is it possible
that this woman is divorced five times
because she just got a bad apple every
single time she got married yeah I guess
it's possible kind of how it's
possible that you would go to a tree
‏at the top of the tree that is possible
right but notable that's not how the
work most usually people who don't know
each other married this one person it
all ended in divorce she seems to be the
common denominator or he seems to be the
common denominator corre and so on we go
so the best determining determinant of
future action
‏arrogance how do someone is arrogant
isn't arrogance in the heart yes
arrogance is in the heart that's where
place is right however is there a
behavior that could manifest itself that
could lead me to the conclusion that
this person has arrogance in his hearts
yes for instance
من اغتال فيته
يقول صلى الله عليه وسلم من تكبر في نفسه
او اختال في مشيته لقي الله وهو عليه
غضبان
[Silence]
‏you
the one who entiallyed
arrogance in we would all kind behavi of
arrogance
that we would be able to tell this is
arrogant person where we learn this from
[Arabic recitation]
have
body langage wrbi
they have are
weر سنه
ان قران سنه
والله اعلم الله وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب
العالمين وجزاكم الله خيرا
‏These guys are dring me phenix